i actually have a question for phil as a
black man
um
i i
we were talking about watching different
news sources someone that i'll tend to
watch sometimes is candace owens i don't
know if you have any strong feelings pro
or against her whatever but what she she
was speaking on a panel one time
um and i remember she was having a
debate with t.i the rapper i think i saw
that okay and she said something to the
effect of the biggest
epidemic going on in america today well
in the black community is the absence of
the black father and basically saying
that's why she doesn't mess with
feminism at all
because uh you know it's a breakdown of
the nuclear family and then and that
basically and i don't know that exact
number i'm sure i'll get it wrong but it
was like
it was like 75 of a young black american
african-american men are raised without
father it could be less could be more
but it was certainly more than 50 i
don't remember the exact number and she
read a quote
by someone
saying uh i had a father i was raised
with a father and you need to have
father and the quote was from tupac one
of your um
um
heroes on your uh on your
painting the point is this um as a black
man you were definitely raised with a
good family i'm sure you've have some
stories on this what are your thoughts
on african americans living without a
father in their life well my parents
divorced when i was three oh okay i
didn't know that right so i didn't hang
out with my biological father
uh very often it was more like uh
you know handful of times here and there
birthday and christmas definitely he
always made sure of those things okay um
but he was kind of absent for majority
of the time and then it wasn't up until
like i was grown that we started
re-establishing a relationship however
he was taken
he passed away seven years ago so around
that time that was like i felt cheated
but you know i was raised by my
stepfather and my mom
um
but they both worked
so they both worked a lot so i was
basically raising myself
at the age of eight nine years old
cooking cleaning for myself you know i
was a you know shoestring kid i was one
of those guys
um
luckily i didn't burn the house down but
you know i had a lot of discipline in
the house and my mom definitely would
have whipped my ass if i would have done
something stupid
but as far as like uh
being taught how to do certain things
you know i did have that available my
family was high on education one of my
step my stepfather he who is still alive
he he had other kids that were much
older than i am
but he made sure that we always had a
personal computer in the house he was
very interested in you know technology
um he worked as a tv engineer for uh nbc
affiliate king five television in
seattle washington so you you had your
stepfather in your life
and my father was doing his thing yeah
you know um what about the the the
bigger picture for you know
african-americans you know i i
definitely feel that it's imperative for
let's just call it what it is i mean
any family dynamic requires a mother and
a father for to raise these kids
absolutely
um
but what candace i believe was saying
that the the absentee father yeah is
creating a big problem
for the african
american community when you're talking
about you just can't have women raising
these kids and expect them to have
exponential growth and be competitive in
the workplace
you know they're missing out on half of
what the other kids are having
period so i definitely think it's
imperative and when you know the
incarcerations of you know
african-american males and you know drug
addictions and these things
you know you have to just play life with
your eyes and realize like use common
sense i mean how is the kid going to
respond
there's only many so many success
stories of a woman having a kid you know
even in their teens or early on and
thinking like wow i can only i can do
this by myself no she's going to require
a ton of help my best friend my best my
best friend who you'll meet
his mom you know shoot she had him when
she was like 15.
and the dad was not around but he's one
of those kids that actually you know had
help you know had a you know a lot of
family around
and um you know he's killing it you know
he's you know executive with aws you
know doing very well for himself but not
every person has that story
there's not most people don't most
people don't think so it's definitely
well they don't but they wouldn't if it
was you know let's just call it what it
is if there's another ethnicity or white
folks
if if if the tables were turned
it's just people
yeah it's just people at the end of the
day
you know you take the you take the white
man out of the kid's life you know you
talk about like uh you know and excuse
me if i say this but like you know
trailer park guys or this that or or
white dudes that just you know
at the end of the day it's just people
you take the male out of the family and
he's non-existent with these kids
especially for a young male
a woman can only do so much shout out to
all the single moms right that have sons
but if they could have it where those
single moms could have a strong man in
their life number one the woman
definitely needs compassionate you know
they need a man
okay they need a partner
but these young boys need men so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you